previo al encuentro de los países de la
otan aumenta la presión sobre Berlín
para que autorice la entrega de los
tanques leopardos a Ucrania un armamento
de fabricación alemana que está
desplegado en varios países de la otan
Aunque el Primer Ministro Hola shells se
ha mostrado reacio a muchos países les
gustaría darnos tanques tiene motivación
para hacerlo y nos están apoyando pero
están esperando los documentos
respectivos de los países que tienen los
derechos respectivos Polonia Finlandia
Portugal España y muchos otros países
están listos para proporcionar una
pequeña cantidad de tanques
Berlín había dicho que sólo entregaría
los looper 2 y Estados Unidos hace lo
mismo con sus tanques abrahams ante lo
que el pentágono mostró su negativa
luego de explicar que los vehículos
estadounidenses requieren de combustible
para aviones mientras que los leopard
trabajan con diesel pero la decisión
final será tomada en la base
estadounidense Rammstein en Alemania
nos reuniremos en Rammstein con nuestros
aliados y socios en el primer encuentro
del grupo de contacto de defensa de
Ucrania y renovaremos nuestro compromiso
conjunto de defensa
la declaración se dio luego de que 11
países de la otan se comprometieran a
enviar artillerías sistemas antiaéreos e
incluso tanques británicos Challenger 2
para hacer frente a la renovada ofensiva
rusa más temprano el presidente del
Consejo europeo Chávez Michelle visitó
kiev y dijo que también está presionando
para que Alemania autorice la entrega de
sus tanques
necesitamos hacer aún más militarmente y
es por eso que estamos escuchando el
mensaje
sistemas de defensa antiaérea sistemas
de artillería municiones y dije ayer
frente al parlamento europeo creo que
los tanques deben ser entregados repito
el llamado que hice ayer ante el
parlamento queremos apoyarlos porque
somos conscientes de Que las próximas
semanas pueden ser decisivas para lo que
viene por eso ahora son necesarias
decisiones
el bloque también impulsa
investigaciones de presuntos crímenes de
guerra cometidos durante la invasión de
Rusia y apoya la creación de un tribunal
internacional dedicado a enjuiciar a los
líderes políticos y militares de Rusia